so first you just see them walking up
and you're like okay
maybe these are new IRS grads they're
excited they're celebrating how cool is
this isn't this awesome we're about to
go play with some I don't know you know
arcade or we're gonna do some Monopoly
then go to minute one go to one minute
halfway through halfway look at this
where's your tax money
[Music]
look at how that guy's holding it
those thumbs you can tell he was in the
military before
what are they saying can you hear that
no they're role-playing as I'm saying
what are the questions they ask
Ed hire a special agent
spread your legs
do you have any other weapons on you
nope
this is real by the way this is not a
movie this is not Saturday Night Live no
this is this is not a spoof this is not
a skid this is not Vincent oshana this
is real okay this is not he's at Nancy
Pelosi's office type of situation this
is really a training that they're doing
with the new IRS agent is this is very
interested in knowing if there's ever
been a training like this before under
any
presidential regime is this is this new
have you ever seen anything like this I
haven't seen anything like it I've never
seen anything like this it's extremely
worrisome well the IRS has been
weaponized for for years now whether or
not the training happened they've had
millions and millions of dollars in
weapons and ammunition for years yeah
how long 10 years 15 years so this this
goes over multiple presidents why does
the IRS need weapons
because
as in any tyrannical state
you have to rule by fear
yeah but according to our friend Tyler
over here this has been going on for
decades
official where are we saying tyrannical
are you saying the American we've been
marching up toward
tyranny
and we're getting close to the top of
the staircase
so it this is uh from Forbes uh official
report says at the end of 2017 the tax
agency had 4 487 guns and over 5 million
rounds of ammunition in its weapons
inventory this was puppeted by the uh
excuse me published by the government
accountability office
um so and this was a report at the end
of 2017. so who knows how long they've
had the weapons for right you don't buy
4 500 guns in a year but walk me through
why the IRS would need weapons
uh to intimidate people
to make people understand
that you could die if you don't
do what we tell you to do
this is like literally who's the guy
that said uh why do you rob banks no
that's where the money is that's that's
the Well from physical representation of
that they have to come and get your
money
how else are they going to continue
this ridiculous spending but who's where
are they coming up and give me your tax
revenue are they going to businesses are
they going to individuals are they going
to corporations when is this well
assault happening obviously they're not
going to be going up to the billionaires
and the people that they claim that
they're going after they're going to be
coming after Average Joe that's why they
need so many people with guns with guns
and they've been practicing I saw an
article yesterday or the day before
of
raiding homes and suburbs
I mean I if if this is not a wake-up
call for us I I don't know what is
I'd like to know who leaked that video
or like who put that video out there
this is very disconcerting regardless of
your life how do you feel about it
obviously that's how you feel about it
that's why I'm like
what is this what is happening exactly
like when they're doing these classes
who's putting these classes on who who's
running the show here that anyone left
or right if you don't see this and say I
don't think that's exactly too
comforting yeah you're missing the point
and this is not really a Democrat or
Republican issue this is an issue of
America and American freedom I agree on
who we are as a nation and you know
people have got to wake up
I think they are waking up to be honest
with you I I think things have been
pushed so rapidly that a lot of the
people who were slumbering
are waking up so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]